I thought that it was just gonna be you
and me and he'll tell you I was like oh
you're here today yeah I thought was
just hey wait a man I know I know me
neither
please shut up was I think your phone up
and text somebody no good [ __ ] sport
oh man that's not quite - a
dermatologist I have a point of view on
[ __ ] basketball and I you're falling
I disagree with what you guys are saying
and and also it is you guys to forget
about the south and it's also cool
because um hey man that's my wallet
get in there if you pay for the SAT
scores oh hey Christ don't be stuck
you're on the podcast right now don't be
a dick don't say so don't do that
listen I want to ask you a question I
we're looking at your Wikipedia page I'm
here with Eric Griffin I'm with Brendan
Schaub yeah yeah I know you know those
guys okay do I turn into a racer
Andrew what's up bro what's up Andrew
Santino hey Brian what the hell dude I
said I didn't know okay I was in Africa
take it easy oh so yeah dude I saw I saw
it it take it easy I just do this hold
on comes there like it feels on truck
what get them out of my chair crazy dude
this is my podcast now you can't just
take over the podcast for the Rat King
to be sting in the red rocket you're
[ __ ] out
rocket is the peace thing tonight you
come now the revolution has begun Jesus
Christ you guys are fine this is a
mutiny don't I hey guys hey guys what's
building yeah kill him
okay say goodbye a box you guys say
goodbye say goodbye to your fans cuz
it's over the time has come say goodbye
to your fans it's over we've been voted
off the island you've been voted off bro
he's a survivor survivor pocket I'm just
oh yeah is this new blood in the old
blood right hold my gun man I know we
saw Brian live so is he yawning is that
what he's doing there so not cool just
trying to get you a Rolex but what am i
what are you doing it's a fake laughing
dude you're doing a high I'm successful
and so is he
not so much hey what the [ __ ] charge
just saying this is my play sure you're
showing up a news clip wearing my
sweatshirt you're trying to promote your
brand with my just workout news that's
cashmere sweater yes that's a [ __ ]
Russell Athletic Center from dick take
it back - I'm not taking it back right
now get it you can't even fix that in
the color code what are you trying to
adjust the color [ __ ] gray [ __ ] you guys
great what's not great tix brings out my
eyes hey you don't have eyes right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue Oh
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]
shut up Brian will you finally give a
[ __ ]
well well kind of will yeah let's see
what I said to [ __ ] Chris D'Elia Oh
serious Mia who who's that listen if
you're feeling froggy you got head and
leap all right now you're looking for
trouble and you're being disrespectful
downing water table here trouble here
okay
drop here no no no why don't you go get
me a [ __ ] almond milk lot yeah yeah
good for nothing meal - you guys are
making me up bein a male right now and
I'm into sports
I know Stephan Pires Steph Curry went
off gold stayed off see the it's almost
unfair how you arch your back like a
Chiquita banana hey Timmy yeah a [ __ ]
disrespect you let that one go on your
own pie I'm gonna let that one go now
I'm gonna let that you came up real
close to my face I'm gonna let that go
and I'm gonna describe all right bro
guide your wrist pin and [ __ ] off
smacked you do it one more [ __ ] time
and then what I'm coming at you do me a
favor if you decide to step into that
ring and I'm being dead serious go I'm
being dead so no gloves make sure no
gloves make sure gloves no gloves um
we're talking about a street fight make
sure well you set a ring right make sure
you if you step over the line
we got gloves all right well if somebody
if we happen to cross a ring in street
is the Alzheimer's kick in then do you
see that your meds today you're all over
bro - yeah that's all I take yeah throw
piece I told the hair the hair stuff
yeah but nothing else
you don't take something for your pee no
I don't and I don't need anything for my
pee pee look at that ever taken viagra I
bet you take peepee pills I don't you
take peepee hair and you take calcium
pills I
don't take calcium pills yes because
your bones no my bump or not stay at my
bone stuck that I've seen them what's
the density of your bones like titanium
titanium yeah like titanium bones
they're stupid don't worry
let's job hit you as hard as you can in
your thigh you could hit me anywhere he
wants okay but just know this know this
if you guys if you want to street fight
with me yeah pack a [ __ ] lunch bro
I'd say package you're gonna be there y
gonna fight all day if they got DNA in
30 years what are they gonna have
besides DNA they're gonna be able to tap
into your brain and and get a map of
your brain dude you know what they're
gonna have which is horrifying as your
old headshots
[Music]
Nick it's not that bird it's not that
much of a bird mm it's not it's not that
much of a burn stop covering the oh my
god it's not that big of a bird it's not
that bad oh that's so obnoxious oh all
right
those all right who got me a little bit
you didn't get me a lot oh you are gonna
have you're gonna hear here's a picture
right here you see the bottom right ages
at the red eyes [ __ ] oh the red eyes
hey that one right there that's more
like oh my god Oh optical cavity is a
[ __ ] oh that's me oh man that's a real
real big keep that I can't talk I don't
I sound like when I drop when I when I
[ __ ] dust a little twist ACMA and the
spider home how about little cookies
potty owl a little crooked teeth but I
don't has a ring for little crooked
teeth I don't have crooked teeth yo yo
yo a little crooked teeth I said I don't
have to cook my you know like that no
there's RIT that kind of you're not
crooked
not the Invisalign work so let's call it
worked Oh yo little wrinkled please
change your little wrinkled face it's a
little wrinkled face up in here y'all
little wrinkled face now you got a
couple little wrinkles up in this [ __ ]
red wrinkles red wrinkled face its
grandfather clock yo my wrinkled face no
it's droopy balls his long ball twin
state seein red wrinkled face aka aka
low balls a k the crow's feet the crow's
feet
aka prune balls a k-leather faith and I
was just doing some weird face I was
clearly swollen that looks like who's
like the morning before I was growing
beards that's the morning where my face
is all swollen cuz I would drink well
that's the nighttime in the rain
somewhere happy Father's Day this is my
son Bryan Callen I'm his father in many
ways but the most important thing is I
am his father in the main way meaning I
had sex with happy Father's Day oh you
goddamn [ __ ] goddamn you to hell that's
attitude you sit down in the guest seat
sit down in the guest seat sit that we
shatters not happy man your lace started
sit down in the gues seat look tell us
what your issues are and you're gonna
make I come on come on come on three TV
shows is okay as you know right okay and
sometimes scheduling can be okay so what
that break [ __ ] am I sitting in this
chair for cuz you today you can't just
pull your way into my tell you you're
bigger I don't know how I'm gonna get
you out you're a guest I truly believe
that the reason you are working a lot
you're talking to is roomy because you
have red hair I mean I want to say that
don't see I'm not I hate to say but
let's be honest that's the own they got
a check box about talent though they got
a check box I don't think you'd be I
don't think you'd be working or B I
don't think you'd be doing a lot of
snail
don't get bad bro don't give that bro
dude I'm talented I'm smart I'm
hard-working I'm on every single night
in my [ __ ] life you think it's the
[ __ ] red hair I'll shave this [ __ ]
right hair off house don't get more work
no you won't don't Ryan don't you even
start with me right now okay just
because you're honest spin out for the
Goldbergs on school and that's gonna do
very well which I'm proud of you for and
I would never down you for that don't
take away my ability my hard work my
ethics I have nothing in this business I
came here with no money I have no family
I'm not Jewish
I made it alone I made it alone Brock
hey I know that don't you know I'm Jude
you're turning the key on the red
Ferrari you want to [ __ ] rip me out I
guess I will burn out all over this
place I misspoke I misspoke I fire wrong
bro no I did my mom man you know better
because I've earned this no I know
you've heard did you earn your position
in this game I did with regular hair
here's the thing your regular hair no
I'm just saying regular hair all red
everybody knows that a ginger has you I
see you right away you do you do pop
yeah I pop yeah and I stand out okay
guess what I have to deliver harder when
they see your normal-looking hair ass on
stage they just go this is just a normal
goofy looking [ __ ] white guy goofy
I'm not well you are goofy looking
there's no doubt who says goofy those
years have been bowing out a little bit
as we gotten older like doors it's hard
doors that are olsun no yeah yeah
they've been bawling out of like an
audience don't see bowing I think we
should pin him back you should tie it
you should tie floss from one side to
the other and pull him back at night no
that is a procedure you know I went out
yeah you sure you like it let's say for
the reason say Finn was born with huge
yes the Sun never hits his face okay I'm
glad you can find this way so it's like
jumbo let's say something good is that
where that collocation you know you know
they can't they they snip it and clips
have been pulling back it looks normal
Wow so kids don't get bullied anymore so
they see you also die kids you could die
you could dye your hair but they see you
want stage and they go let's see what
this [ __ ] regular Joe Schmoe has to
do you come up there with some of your
you know jokes whatever I know no I know
some of them are good i watch actually a
couple nights ago and i thought wow
that's better than you know used to be
okay and you and you'd sling your jokes
and they go good yeah I'm glad he was
good but he's normal I get up the
they go was this guy what is this guy
yoga and then I [ __ ] murder and they
go wow yeah Wow he overcame something do
you have any red head jokes not really
Moreland and you had no don't do your
accents my accents are so spot-on those
let me ask you a question seriously yeah
what little boy is freezing outside
because you stole his outfit you stole
his whole outfit look at that little
boy's shirt you have on dude this is the
little thing oh I love all set yeah but
that shirt well it's a little boy shirt
okay listen
yeah it the stripes that go this way are
flattering they're a horizontal stripes
for those of you listening to this make
my was make my shoulders but it makes
Brian bring out as brought my shoulder
oh my shoulders for the broadness that
they actually are you kind of you look
like you're you know what you did you
look like you put on the outfit and then
grow up that's what you look like that's
what you [ __ ] look like what the [ __ ]
my future oh [ __ ] dude hey put your [ __ ]
I put my son got you brought this up
yeah cuz I want to ask you I had to put
it I had to put my sunglasses on so
obnoxious cuz your future so bright yeah
that's exactly yeah okay so you get it I
don't get it cuz I want to ask you
seriously I want to get I want to get
serious and I want to I want to start
reading question alright start with a
future so bright sucks the man I need to
wear sunglasses endorsed you don't I
want to start with this question right
let's start with the general I'm ready
right I'm looking at you got holes in
your jeans you guys cuz I live life I
live life a little I know I know so
let's start with this number will will
dilate down you know what that means I
know it dilate means man but so I read
bro you know okay but so you read you
know he read Twitter so no no I really
no I'm gonna read and comments but no
I'm gonna read soon your tombstone in
five years because you oh good I'll be
there
what's my tombstone in the saying what
are you gonna say them if you know what
it said honestly YouTube's I was gonna
say he tried it's gonna be dot dot dot
question mark it's gonna trail off your
tombstone hunter trail off no what are
you gonna say at my funeral I asked you
to speak I'm gonna honestly go like this
I'll speak and then I'll go on there and
then it'll be like ladies and gentlemen
Chris D'Elia
and everyone you know when they're done
cheering or whatever like I'm good
I know I don't guys guys guys he died
guys he died I'm gonna have to say that
a [ __ ] little [ __ ] load yeah
and I'm gonna be up there with my iced
americano sipping and disrespectful but
I know but it's I know but funerals are
early so so uh so I wanna be like guys
he lived life and he he changed the
world in the little ways that people do
sometimes and also now sadly I'm gonna
let out a big [ __ ] rip fart I'm gonna
let out a [ __ ] huge just [ __ ] oh oh
it's gonna come out like that and I'm
gonna go like this oh [ __ ] I'm sorry and
then I'm gonna take my sunglasses off
and I'm gonna go with my mouth and I'm
gonna [ __ ] have two big middle fingers
I'm not gonna do it like they do like
that I like it I'm gonna [ __ ] it and the
whole thing's and I'm gonna go like this
my new special comes out whenever and
whatever time you're using an item
launching pad and you're gonna
disrespect me by yeah one thing what
sunglasses off in the middle of it
though let's just get into it man yeah
Brian's late eft-1 sends me it takes it
goes bro lost track of time be there
soon who loses track of time I don't
even know what that is by the way I
don't even know what losing track of
time is but here's the problem we've
been doing the show for six years
yeah it's the same time every Wednesday
yeah if it but it's so you know it's not
like oh it's a crazy Thursday and yeah
except I suppose whatever I guess it was
just me I'm used to it yeah I do too I
used to have inner demons mm think about
killing Brian would he'd be late to me I
probably quit the show four to five
times because he's late all the time
yeah and they stop being late he hasn't
been late in a while yeah it used to be
a real problem
yeah I'm just like a chalk it up it's
Brian yeah but you can kind of see that
with Brian's progression in life he lost
track it's always been losing track of
yeah and now it's really hitting them
and now it's like hey i'ma do a special
that's like I think he lost track of
time
yeah that should have been done 15 years
ago but yeah hey good job
well boom oh you would try to bring that
foot I bet you didn't know that Brown
has been 87 shades of brown listen up we
got 150 reach my face with your foot cuz
I move so quickly and I can measure
distance and you and kick and you to
overstep and then your [ __ ] face with
you and I would go yeah yeah I go boop
boop boop
I understand combinations boop boop yes
whack and you go meet me and [ __ ] your
pants how did your pants enough to run
away hey how did that guy what was that
guy the Crocodile Hunter rock it out
Dundee no the guy passed away Steve
Irwin Steve alright now how did he die
I'm already annoyed with this giant
[ __ ] water bottle of yours man you
drink too much water broke
you just do you drink too much water you
can't excuse me drink enough water I
can't take it
how did you see one guy he had he got he
tried to pet a stingray from what I
understand yeah and it's shot it's it's
barb into his heart and God bless the
man he passed away
how BIG's a stingray I don't know will
was probably a very big stingray
probably had a wingspan of about six to
eight feet okay
now we're gonna go ahead and say we're
gonna go ahead and put the over-under at
under when we say that my foot is the
size of a stingray it's probably a
little smaller right it's a little
smaller but not by much I don't believe
in getting pedicures okay so if you come
close to me and I'm just wagging my foot
around and I just send a gnarled yellow
toenail don't into your chest I cut you
don't do I cut you ill leave out no I'm
not touching you get your finger this is
on our podcast getting buffing where the
[ __ ] bro I'm warning you I can't be on
the telephone no I can push I can be
pushed just so far that's not my voice
is so good though I have good skin oh
yeah excuse hey Nick I look 51 okay no
you know you do have good skin yeah yeah
how's Rises a bummer how old are you
Nick 41
I've really known you since you were 19
yeah literally a weird that's crazy
that is [ __ ] weird men you do a good
skin though yeah who's your
dermatologist where marshal bill or
that's not I don't even think it's funny
dude
so why are you laughing at your joke
you're laughing at your own joke no I
wasn't yeah you were you know I guess a
lot your beard money comes out of it the
funny can I like that I made you he did
not make me no but that's what I learned
from you is to not do it you know I like
that I molded you and they didn't hold
me at all if I did I broke it it was it
was him named Chris D'Elia
no wonder you listen what I mean is that
I liked that you were in the nest I was
feeding my with some no and then I lay
down and night when you grew feathers I
released you and that's what I know
where's my camera
there's only one camera by the way where
is it worth like oh you're talking it's
a podcast I understand it just know that
if I want to shoot you out of the sky
mm-hm
they won't happen dude look oh wow oh
thank God for him huh what you don't
mean what do you do no one's listening
to the kid right [ __ ] if you really
think about it your turn if you really
think about it if this splits the show
split yeah no one's listening to the
[ __ ] okay dude that's about what 5% of
the [ __ ] hey you don't know that you're
I have metrics watch what happens I have
analytics where do you get those I know
someone here what's his name Korean guy
Koreans no [ __ ] I'm just saying Koreans
a good complain shins Korea where's my
camera to all my Korean people you know
you're not going but no seriously
they're already thinking about the
fighter pod does that even that even
flows good divider
key pointer kid what who old news broken
grads knowledge that I had I heard two
really cool Japanese concepts that my
friend Hunter mots
explained on Nick's mental arts my other
podcast what no it's my bad
well yeah do you know for 10 points do
you know the two Japanese concepts of
iki guy and kutsuki Katsuji yeah Katsuji
is you know what I like to do make a
sound and see if it's an Asian circuit
do it in China tell you alright you know
write one down you still country what
about this one dude do you I'm not a kid
that sounds Vietnamese boom and this is
why when you are a guy who you know is
you and you're what five 170 right how
you characterize doesn't matter because
boxing and [ __ ] and the reason it made
me laugh from the bottom of my gut is
that if you ever step to me give a [ __ ]
if we're in the theater class yeah I'll
give a [ __ ] if we're on a cruise today
or where we are I'll fold you a full jet
no yes and I'll toss you on top of the
tallest building I see no that there's a
two-story building the seams here what
are we on the third floor here yeah so
this has got three floors this place
yeah all the all the places in this
whole complex three pretty cool stuff
yeah there's lots of great [ __ ] outside
there's I was walking in I saw a food
truck yeah everyone was ordering stuff
yeah careful now looks like it's a good
thing yeah if we were out there and I
was in line and I was like yeah hi
chicken Caesar no peanuts and then you
walked up and you shoved me out of the
way and you look three food store cool
and I would just fold you and turn you
around and I would start spitting and I
go there it it and it's like oh there's
one and three stories up [ __ ] you you'd
wake up gravel rash on the roof just
crumpled up against an air conditioning
unit what the [ __ ] a pity you
you'll get gravel rash so be some guys
up there
they'll be up there tar in the gravel
with their hot mops and you'll go watch
oh you got a little you're hot it's hot
up there you got some tar on guitar you
got gravel rationalism public yes little
bony of my pants yeah a little [ __ ] a
little [ __ ] in your pants listen I
appreciate what you're saying and I get
it I'm not a regular guy I got a lot of
tricks here that's the same thing as
Chad I'll get willing again I've been
sitting down the punches lately doing a
lot of sparring a measuring time's up on
hunch stop calling women hon your pineal
eye delivery are you ordering some mr.
good bars is that to get your oh Henry
[ __ ] man sweetie okay sweetie pie doing
no I'm recording a show I don't know
what's happening right now B what's
happenin I've been here since 12:15 you
won't know these names but would you
rather be Tom Brady and Derek Jeter or
LeBron James yeah did miss Ryan's like
what who are those people it's not a
good impression of oh my god do they
sell hotdogs that's it
Javan that's a [ __ ] I've never done that
my beard is gray and I just didn't give
a [ __ ] about anything else it's just one
thing that I like doing and then I just
you took you know it was zero and I want
to like the math master not that's
another thing I want to talk about is we
were talking about this before we
started recording
you used to be laid all the time yeah
and now you're not yeah because you just
changed that I just changed and that
means that you're an even bigger [ __ ]
than I thought
yeah because no because he was just
being late and he could change it like
that
well no means you were trying to make a
joke but I don't hurt my feelings man
like I said forgive me late I don't want
to do this yeah I thought once I went
off hurting my friend I looked and I go
I will never be late again
oh interesting he hasn't been late you
know what what one of the things that he
did what once we were at dinner I think
I probably told this maybe on another
podcast but we were at dinner it was me
you Josh Lawson Will Sasso and Craig
culture I think I called him Chuck what
I say
Chad Cole yeah chuckles and and someone
else yeah and Tom Cruise no it wasn't
Tom created I hang out with those guys
so I don't I always confuse them okay so
anyway yeah wasn't them okay so uh and
and I had a set and and and and Chad and
and and Josh were like yeah I don't know
I don't know if they ever see me do
stand-up so they're gonna come to the
comedy store you gonna come so he yeah
so I got to go I want to make sure I get
on so meet me at the comedy source well
I left early and then all you all you
guys want to go to the comedy store I
get on so I was like just so you know
everyone's coming I was got him seats I
got onstage I get offstage and I'm like
what the [ __ ] is everybody you guys
weren't there and then and then Josh or
Chad I was talking and they were like
hey uh yeah or when you come in and I
was like what am i comment on what I was
like you guys were suppose we made the
comment so where the [ __ ] are you guys
and he says oh you uh Mariah said you
were going up at the improv and I was
like what you said Brian said you were
you you rotate you changed it and you
were going to the prom
laughs I remember that no no no was
Brian doing stand-up yes [ __ ] just
one no I actually think it was worse
than that he just wanted to be at the
improv
because he liked the hang there better
and everyone was like he just lied to
them and said nag Cruces - instead of at
the improv let's go there it's like and
I called him like this [ __ ] and
he didn't say hello the first thing
because he knew like what he did was
dead yeah he picks on the phone he says
you ruined the night I went to call
Chris I called him and I get a text he
doesn't pick up the phone I get a text
and all it says is nah yep well ladies
and gentlemen it is the fighter and the
Vaughn cuz yeah it is late as [ __ ] well
so we gonna strike it up bro well it's
ironic that the kid behaves like one
right that's rough Jackson goes bro
super late lost track of time
and I and I just respond back you're 50
yeah you're 50 years old
that's what this is this Brian the kid
lost track of time
my favorite is he's gonna come back I
thought we said one yeah oh say dude
there's a pipe that busted off the 405
I'm like well no I took about five here
yeah hook up with some crazy can
advocate in here yeah right so we got
him cornered yeah we I'm true yeah fire
dude this guy I've never been around
anybody who been around this many fires
every another other place with him oh
the huge fire huge fire on La Cienega
sure guy he told me one he goes dude a
water main broke off Pacific
why the [ __ ] anywhere there I live off
Pacific yeah little water main I gonna
lie we engage I go really
no then same thing of the [ __ ] way
enough water everywhere bro well he also
has a scanner he's and here's the thing
you people that are laid and constant
and laid and you know just selfish with
other people's times that's what it is
it's helped us with other people's time
you know yeah how its up but I saw you
last night how's your set the Comedy
Store
it was good to draw bond is [ __ ]
amazing like it changed your life yes
and and you know and I'm happy for him
because for years nothing was happening
for
hey where's now know that lots of things
hangover yeah nothing happened I think
you're a man yeah I was on man no one
even knew gave up man that's the message
we're trying to say I don't think that
somebody's talented friend it happens 65
- 65 this podcast - Sarah boy you don't
know that 60 60 I like I wouldn't want
to kill myself 60 like what am I doing
with my life
satellite sabbatical water earned it all
that's how I stop calling myself the kid
let's have an old man wearing hip
clothes I'll [ __ ] talk like that jo
koy take it back what are you doing
right now I saw this episode of him take
you to shirt off in boxing you can roll
the tits no I don't you have old got a
great ass
I'll take it back up he had old man buff
no I don't maybe 13 years maybe 13
that's a long last time yeah it's like a
time warp it doesn't nothing changes
Kalin doesn't get any older as if he
does so if he does yeah just keep saying
he's not older then one day he's just
not gonna show it died from old age
we're just hating on him he'll die in a
fire
I know I know I finally something
happens finally a water main breaks and
he dies in it that's when we find out he
wasn't lying
we've got the femurs above some new
material no all right man that's bra but
he's like Bobby Lehman I can watch his
for I can watch his show and even though
it'll evolve some it's just it's still
funny every time yeah yeah they have a
unique gift of the dynamic yeah you can
just look at them and they're funny you
know correct it's a nice but yeah
there's some element there where their
punchline has already set up he's a lot
of community have to write the punchline
buh-buh-buh-buh-buh yeah but more
performance comedian yeah wait where
I think that like I always say this
about Callen I think he's better in
person than he is if you listen to him
on audible or on visually yeah I'm video
in person is where you get the fool you
get that fire yeah if he shows up if he
shows that I took and he shows up he's
half an hour late now that's whatever
yeah and Counting yeah this right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue
good what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do use some of that boxing you've
been doing
[Laughter]